we talked about uh the some of the what
was your favorite coach you played for
was it because I played for Larry Bird
right yeah Larry
so like Larry Larry got mad at me from
the day I met him I missed my flight for
my press conference oh so he was he's
already was like yeah he just he like
being like being late is the worst thing
you could do with him as being late he
does not play that [__] so literally the
first time I met him I walked into the
office and he was like I don't play that
late [__] before he said hi happy to
have you on the team he's like I don't
play that late [__] that's some [__]
and I felt like he always held that
against me the two years I was there but
Larry was not a coach per se he was a
gay manager uh we had a guy because you
had you had like red like Chris Mullen
and all this but you still gotta run
plays right right he never did that like
he he never wrote in two years never
wrote an x-ro oh really never once he
had uh Rick Carlisle our offensive coach
great coach by the way yep and then we
had uh the coach uh Brendan Malone so he
just had like coordinators yeah exactly
and he was he just subbed he just turned
around like oh you get this person hey
time
he's calling timeout to seven that's
what he would do but my favorite coach
was um so I would say my best X and O
coach was Rick Carlisle shout out to Ray
Carlos like bro whatever he draws up
works every time you're gonna get an
open shot for sure every time
um he's back in Indiana right back in
Indiana but my my favorite coach that I
enjoyed playing for was where I had when
we had the least amount of success was
Mike Wilson Michael that was for them oh
that was in it oh that's right you were
with the Hawks for him because like I
got traded for Steven Jackson when the
malice in the Palestine so that was my
that that was my favorite coach and the
reason why I liked him so much was once
again man I'm just a huge I I you know
I'm huge on like integrity and just like
just being straight up with people and
like I just felt like the two years I
was with him he never lied to me once
bro he told me whether I liked it or not
you know what I'm saying he told me what
was the truth and uh you know for that
Joe Johnson was on that team Joe came
the next year my first year no joke
first year was like second year he had
Joe second year we had Joe first year
was like me Antoine Walker Kevin Willis
rookies we had like Josh Smith Josh
Childress oh shout out to Josh Childress
man one of the greatest Pros in NBA
history Uh Kevin Willis had to be like
50. wait no he played how old he was he
played so long it's crazy yo did Joe
Johnson ever like confide in you how he
felt about how the sons did because I
felt like if we would have kept Joe
Johnson I feel like
we might have had a championship bro we
let Joe Johnson just walk because yeah
but he came I mean I mean and then he
goes to the Hawks and then they become a
perennial playoff team yeah he was one
of the most underrated players you know
what I'm saying of his time for sure but
hey man I saw Joe was a monster did you
guys uh ever trade back and forth about
uh like later on how much you guys
didn't like Mike dantoni
I want to see me and him never had a
conversation about Mike but I might hit
him up and ask him though okay so what
was yeah what was it like yeah did you
really hate this guy uh well look man um
obviously the the so can you kind of
break down because I don't think a lot
of people understand a lot of the
business model when it comes to
the weed game I think a lot of people
think it's like like we're talking off
off the air it's like you get in the
weed game and you just print money which
is not the case so many companies they
they they're they're here for six months
they're here for two years and then
they're gone like you said you you're 12
years in for you guys
are you guys
strictly distro wholesale
um you guys don't have a dispensary
license do you yeah so my my company got
a bunch of layers to it you know what
I'm saying um a lot of markets yeah we
had a bunch of markets we're in I think
we're in like 10 markets total
um in a variation of different like ways
right so uh for the viola brand you know
we have uh cultivated or operated in
California Oregon Michigan and Colorado
um to your point now the entry has
changed so much
um I think the asset light uh approach
which means to what you said focusing on
wholesaling focusing more on just The
Branding
um you know the sell through and
different things like that is probably
the way to go if you're trying to scale
a brand almost like the kind of cookies
model yeah
um but even that's difficult because
then you got to have a hell of a
procurement team and make sure like the
quality control is Right quality control
is the main thing right it's everything
right but you know so either way it's
very difficult both ways right
um we also have started opening up some
retail locations through like sister
company that we have called Village
um you know so Viola owns a percentage
of village and all of the Village
locations are named Viola so we have so
you guys do have sore fronts so yeah so
we have two uh we have two in Missouri
okay we have two in Illinois it's about
to open up we have one in Jersey we're
about to open we're about to open one up
in Maryland uh you know we hope to get
something going down in Florida
um and then also New York we're working
on New York currently is it crazy for
you to go to New York as a kid from the
east coast and see how open the week
like have you been in New York City
recently of course it is like
the craziest [__] I've ever seen it's
like like people think like it's Federal
legalization people think like
California is like everyone's out here
smoking weed now you go to New York and
you're just walking in the park and
there's a bunch of dudes with fold up
tables selling drugs it's crazy they're
cops or you go to the store to buy a
juice and a sandwich and the guy behind
the back he's got all kind of weed and
shrooms and [__] it's [__] wild yeah
New York and it happens New York is
definitely the Wild Wild West they
decriminalized and everybody just is
NYPD just don't care they're just like
hey dude at the end of the day which is
good it's prohibition right great yeah
sometimes you gotta you gotta take
advantage it's just wild to see they're
like contrast yeah it's crazy you know
to your point like I remember there was
a point you like you said you you know
you rode through the city I mean one
time I had got some weed in New York and
I was still playing but it's the
summertime and I got pulled over and I
just picked up a couple ounces from
somebody and it would have my whole car
stinking and I was so scared yeah and
the cop took my stuff and everything and
you know I told him it's a new truck
that's why the plate was wrong whatever
and he literally my license and
insurance back and was like stop smoking
in the car I hadn't even smoked I was
just you know what I'm saying but he
could have literally locked me up for it
yeah you know what I'm saying to like to
your point now I could be blazing he
pulled me over like what's up you want
to hit this
you know what I'm saying so it's
definitely changed a lot and you know I
think that the New York program on the
legal side is probably going to be one
of the best in the industry I think
because of the way that they are trying
to make sure that
um Legacy
um people that were disproportionately
affected by the war on drugs are like
winners and that are participating in
the beginning and not in the you know
later like most States because most
States they give all these big companies
these opportunities then they say okay
now we're going to let you know the
people that you know the poor people get
in and I always say like I used a
comparison is like playing against the
Warriors and spotting them 20 30 points
and then saying go out and play
literally what happened yeah you know
what I'm saying so when New York they're
doing it you know totally they're doing
it the right way they're rolling it out
properly and um I'm excited for the New
York Market I think it's going to be
probably the biggest in the country